I thought at seven years old the coolest
thing I could do with my time instead of
playing Wiffle ball or doing whatever
was literally to stand on the corner
of Interest literally standing on the
corner of cross streets and
intersections in New Jersey and would
sit there and just watch every car drive
by and try to figure out which tree or
Pole to put the sign on because that's
where their eyes were like this is sick
but in hindsight it's the biggest thing
I want to talk about today which is do
you pay attention to where attention is
if you understand where attention is
literally almost everything that's
running through your beautiful mind
right now of what you'd like to
accomplish in your business can be
reverse engineered good morning
little Bone Thugs-N-Harmony always gets
me in the right mood
I'm really happy to be here especially
because it's been a journey to get here
so and I'm actually really excited about
the way Serendipity and the world works
I think a lot of the things that I'd
like to talk about and why I'm pushing
for a lot of q a
um because I think there's a lot of
details that need to go into what I'm
about to talk about in headlines I would
argue is probably more relevant today as
we head into
the business dynamics that I think are
emerging in 2023 not only potential
recession things of that nature but a
ridiculously changing landscape when it
comes to leadership of empowering
employees and how significant marketing
is changing at a level that we haven't
seen in a very very long time including
the Advent of social media the way
social media is evolving right this
second has a profound impact on what I
think you can control well you know
being a businessman my whole life over
the last 15 years working with Fortune
500 companies and being an investor and
being on a lot of boards one of the most
interesting models for me personally in
the world is the franchising franchise
or model and it comes with so many
unique dynamics that all of you are
living all of them are living and I
think the thing that has always excited
me the most is somebody who has a lot of
friends and relatives people I really
like acquaintances that are franchisees
of businesses is how much more those
franchisees can do in today's world than
versus the 80s and 90s and 2000s right
obviously the Advent of the internet 25
years ago and how it's evolved and
matured to where we are today just gives
everybody here a lot more control about
driving demand into their stores than
anything we've seen in the last 50 years
of this model and I think that's
something I'd really like to touch on
and and really the other thing I'd like
to touch on is
a little bit of like the dynamic of what
we're seeing with how to manage our
managers and some of the things I think
you might be going through operationally
I think there's so many headlines of
like great resignation myths and gen Z
that and recession there's just a ton of
data and a lot of inputs out there and I
think I want to touch on that maybe spur
some q a on that because I think that
could bring the most value taking a step
back just to give you context of how my
brain works and where I want to take
this and where I think the value sits is
for me I was you know born in the Soviet
Union I came to the US when I was three
and unlike most immigrant kids from
Europe during the 80s I was not getting
straight A's in school and educations
the way out I just had entrepreneurial
DNA from the get from the moment I could
like literally remember I was selling
something you know when I was six I
tricked all my friends in the
neighborhood to stand behind my lemonade
stands so I've been in the business
you've been in for a long time when I
was six seven years old I literally had
a lemonade franchise
I convinced may she rest in peace my
great friend Marissa Byrd Robbie turnick
Andy Greco Eric Godfrey I literally
convinced them to stand behind the
lemonade stand tables around the
neighborhood and I would make signs
all day long and I would literally walk
around
the neighborhood you know for the
youngsters in here who's under 30 raise
your hands under 30. raise them high
don't be scared
yes so for you kids this is crazy we
used to play outside
so this was the 1983-4-5 and I would
literally you know my mom would throw me
outside at 9am we came back for lunch we
came back for dinner like we were out
and I was marketing and I was obsessed
at six seven years old with one thing
and it took me I don't think I
remembered this until 10 years ago when
my career was going a certain way and I
was trying to be I started being much
more retrospective and how did I get
here and what are the pillars that are
making me not only be successful but to
be very Frank happy so many of my
friends who are eight figure nine figure
ten figure incomes and networks just a
shocking amount of them are unhappy and
so that really affected me in the last
10 years I was like what is this why
does this work for me so I've been very
introspected for the last 10 years and I
recalled this is crazy I would convince
my friends to have all these lemonade
stands and I would literally I thought
at seven years old the coolest thing I
could do with my time instead of playing
Wiffle ball or doing whatever was
literally to stand on the corner
of Interest literally standing on the
corner of cross streets and
intersections in New Jersey and would
sit there and just watch every car drive
by and try to figure out which tree or
Pole to put the sign on because that's
where their eyes were like this is sick
but in hindsight it's the biggest thing
I want to talk about today which is do
you pay attention to where attention is
if you understand where attention is
literally almost everything that's
running through your beautiful mind
right now of what you'd like to
accomplish in your business can be
reverse engineered so that's why it was
at seven tricking all my friends to my
franchise lemonade Sam business and for
people over 40 in here you might
remember big wheels right it was like a
fake bike I used to go at five or six pm
and ride my big wheels to my four to
five locations and pick up the cash like
I was Tony [ __ ] soprano
so that's why I DNA
sports cards became a big thing they've
recently come back so that might be on
people's radar that was big for me and I
was making a thousand dollars a weekend
selling sports cards when I was 11 12
years old which no matter how much
wealth I created my life was definitely
the richest I've ever been and ever will
be because when you have ten thousand
dollars under your bed in cash and
you're 12 and you're not selling weed
you're a real [ __ ] entrepreneur
and then my life shifted and I think
this is where I connect with so many of
you my light shifted very aggressively
at 14. I was like winning and doing this
amazing stuff and then I don't know how
many of you have Soviet fathers but when
your Soviet father owns a liquor store
in New Jersey and you turn 14 your life
changes and so on my 14th literally this
is how gangster my parents are on my
actual 14th birthday my dad's like
you're coming to the store and I worked
in the liquor store that day and I went
from making a thousand dollars a weekend
selling sports cards to making two
dollars an hour for 14 hours a day
bagging ice in the basement of my dad's
liquor store for the next two years
I don't know how many people by show of
hands and don't be scared like the 30
year olds who are high how many people
here saw the movie The Goonies raise
your hand great from 14 to 16 I was
sloth
I was chained to the basement of my
dad's liquor store bagging ice which
really is the greatest thing in
hindsight for me for a lot of you that
are building this business this is a
family business tangent
teaching youngsters the humility of hard
work for little amounts of money is one
of the great gifts you can give your
child I highly recommend it
I highly recommend it
even and I'm going to tell you how it
manifests [ __ ] business is about life
and being a human I one of the great
compliments I can get is what just
happened which is as we were walking
here you know the wonderful people that
were setting me up they're like do you
want a coffee I'm like I can get it like
it's just acting humble like you want
like back to happiness this is kind of
the latest thing that I'm in the lab on
in my flights and in the shower and when
I'm sleeping humility
is such an unlock for happiness
but people just don't want to go there
they make a couple of bucks or get a
blue check and social or have a couple
of followers and they start to think
there's somebody and it's a dangerous
drug ego is just insecurity with makeup
on and I highly recommend to everybody
start to fall in love
I don't I don't like
like you could have 79 locations in this
network and make 43 million dollars a
year and are you a good person are you
happy like so we have to change the
conversation around success but that's
another talk for another day
so I'm in my dad's store and this is
where I really this is where I want to
go with the meat of it I want to give
you some context but growing up in
retail
15 hours a day for real just you know
like my Dad should be in jail for child
labor
every weekend every family vacation like
we didn't have vacations we didn't like
I worked every Saturday for 20 years
like real real stuff I didn't leave my
dad's business until I was 34 years old
so by the way back to the 30 year old
crowd for the people how many people
here consume my content on social raise
your hands thank you so for those people
you know I pound patients I put it out I
believe in it so much I think for a lot
of you here who don't know me or haven't
consumed it I believe patience is
imperative if you want to build
something in a meaningful way I think a
lot of the issues or the shortcomings or
the concerns one has in here is they
have a theoretical number that they've
made up of how much money they want to
make that's completely arbitrary on how
much money at what age and it really
screws people up it makes them take
shortcuts it gets them and see it makes
them feel unhappy so there's a lot there
with like patience and that's what I
deployed I lived in that store for 20
years when I went full time in 1998
after I came back from college
um
the business was doing 3.7 million
dollars of top line revenue and 10
gross profit it was called Shoppers
Discount Liquors for a reason I remember
when I was 16 I was like that when I
started to get to see a little bit under
the hood I'm like Dad why do we you know
we said you buy a case of Budweiser for
12 bucks and you sell it for 12 bucks
I'm like you buy a bottle of absolute
vodka for 15 and you sell it for 15 I'm
like what's that he's like we make it up
in volume
brother said that
but
I'm razzing a little bit but I think
this will make sense for you I believe
in the Lost leader I believe in the
thing that brings people to the store so
I learned that model but the business
was doing 3.7 million dollars in 1998
and by 2003 in a five-year window I grew
that business from a 3.7 million dollar
a year business to a 60 million dollar a
year business
with no Capital infusion no VC money
no credit line because my dad's an
immigrant no credit line
and the way I did it is basically what I
want to talk to you about today the way
I built that business in five years was
based on two core things marketing and
management
on the marketing front
I have a big thesis if anything sticks
for you from a business standpoint in
this talk I'd like you to remember this
term
everybody here
outside of the help that corporate is
doing in marketing that you decide to do
in marketing and here's a good one it
doesn't even require a lot of media
dollars it's not running the advertising
it's about the creative you put out on
social the thing you're always looking
for is the thing I inherently understood
in 1998 that I later understood how to
communicate it it's called underpriced
attention
the number one thing everyone here has
to leave Vegas for and go back if they
want to really substantially grow their
business is becoming great at operating
in underpriced attention underpriced
attention in 1998 was email
how many people here have done email
marketing in their careers close enough
to it that they could have a sense
reason hi I just want to get a set good
so this will make a lot of sense for a
lot of people in 1999 I had an email
newsletter that had 200 000 people on it
that had 90 open rates
so for the people that don't follow
email you're crushing it today with 30
open rates meaning you send an email 30
of them actually open it and then
there's a whole nother thing to do
people even act on it in 1998 I had 90
of the people opening the email because
in 1998 we had it ruined email yet
right you didn't get all the spam you've
got in the last 25 years we were opening
it and I realized very quickly Direct
Mail was working for me but email was
free I remember I was sending so many
emails in 19 here's a here's one
prediction I got super wrong from 1998
to 2000 I sent so many damn emails
because I was convinced that at some
point they were going to charge for this
[ __ ] but like it just didn't make sense
it was too effective I was saving tens
of thousands of dollars on Direct Mail
and radio and doing email for free and
it was crushing that's the underpriced
attention of 1998 having a website doing
email and then finally the day Google
AdWords came out I bought up every wine
term you can imagine for six months
there it wasn't even 10 cents a click
floor it was five cents a click and I
crushed and so in a very short period of
time with absolutely no money
with no money I was able to grow a very
large business and it became the
foundation of how I think
and I sit here today for example how
many people here produce
organic no paid advertising organic
creative and post for their business on
Tick Tock raise your hand
I want to leave right now
one more time raise your hand if you're
posting for tick tock so this is like a
travesty
every single person here whether you
think China's manipulating the kids or
not
foreign
every single person here has to
immediately understand what's Happening
Here on Tick Tock because it's not even
about Tick Tock it's about The Tick-Tock
a vacation of social media
then for as few hands as went up right
now you can't imagine like how the
juices are flowing through my body
because in a good way because for me
30 of what I like about public speaking
is I know this format is the format that
gets somebody to do something that they
haven't been doing and then four years
from now I get the email I mean I live
on positive affirmation so I get the
email of like hey I was at the
conference like this is a big deal ever
this is real now whether you have one
unit or three units or 30 units in this
system
my personal belief by the way I don't
own your business I don't know you so
whether you do this or not is kind of
irrelevant to me other than I know it
will be historically correct and I hope
a lot of you do it and for the people
that raise their hands earlier
one more time people that consume my
content
so all the hands that are up right now
all of you know I've been saying this
for four years this is not this week
for four years I've been talking about
this what's the difference today than 40
years ago is Instagram and YouTube and
Twitter and Snapchat are all now doing
the same thing social for 15 years was
build as many followers as you can and
then post it was almost like email
marketing build a list post a certain
percentage see it that whole game is now
out the window now the creative is the
variable there are people in here who've
never posted on Tick Tock are about to
get motivated by the next 30 minutes
we'll post their first Tick Tock
tomorrow and some of you will get 12
views on that and others will get 13
000 even though all of you have zero
followers
this is you know this is a very profound
thing like I understand I'm like
speaking it a little bit quick
especially if you don't have the context
the fact that you can post videos and
potentially millions of people can see
them
it's a very big deal and if you have not
at least done 10 hours that's all I'm
asking for which is time but you can do
this at midnight you can do this when
you travel back 10 hours of homework
on best and all you have to do like let
me give you a website that all of you
should be referencing to get all the
information for modern marketing by the
hour
I'll I'll spell it out because I know a
lot of you are taking notes
g o o g l e
dot com
you can literally type in how does a
fitness
store do Tick Tock enter how do I make
tick tocks for my gym and anything you
can think of the amount of information
for free is Saturn of course some of it
isn't great which is why I want you to
spend 10 hours so you can cross
reference and not just the first article
I genuinely believe standing on this
stage that if everybody in here spends
five to ten hours getting deeply
educated on best practices
on how to make organic tick tocks or you
can make them Instagram reels Facebook
reels have exploded
and that demo is extremely interesting
for this audience and their locations
but it's all the same practice how do
you make videos that actually bring
people value this is not an infomercial
this is not a commercial this is a video
that brings value to them thus brings
awareness to you thus brings business to
you this is a real commitment the
reality is whoever here out flanks the
rest of the world in producing social
content is going to win what is holding
so many people back here is ideology
there's a lot of people in this room
that are not doing this because they
made a theoretical decision on what it
is or what it can do
but let there be no confusion the data
is very clear the attention of our
society is on these platforms maybe you
wish it was still in magazines maybe you
loved radio for some weird-ass reason
probably you have an issue with it
because social media is being blamed for
humans
activities because to remind everybody
social human social media are empty
pipes they have nothing it just takes
what humans put into it social media
hasn't changed us
social media has exposed us and so maybe
you don't like that I respect that you
can do whatever you want as a human
being as a business owner you don't get
to decide where the customer's attention
is you get to decide if you would like
to execute where the customer's
attention is and grow your business if
you are so theoretical about social that
you would not like to do that for your
business I commend that I find that
admirable it's also a very bad business
strategy
that's up to you I'm unemotional about
it but that is what is happening and so
the reality is is we have this Mass
underpriced attention and let me tell
you why it becomes a humongous deal for
everybody here I don't know if you know
the term CTV or Ott connected television
or over the top but I definitely know
you know what Hulu Netflix Amazon Prime
HBO Max and all the rest are these
platforms
are taking all the attention out of
Television the amount of people here who
watch NBC on Wednesday night at 9 00 PM
is zero zero
commercials have 80 billion dollars in
ad spend a year mainly with the Fortune
500 companies BMW Nike all this those
companies are now especially with a
looming recession coming finally
starting to understand that when they
run a commercial
on a sitcom
or a reality show on cable that they are
taking good cash and lighting it on fire
and throwing it in the garbage this is
what I do for a living in Vayner X if
you saw earlier I run an advertising
agency that has 2 000 employees globally
I've been the Pied Piper for social for
13 years and I can tell you because I'm
in the trenches the biggest companies in
the world are about to reallocate their
money much more into social than
television why am I bringing that up I
believe for the entrepreneurs in this
room there's a 24 to 36 month window
when the getting is good it's not as
good as it was four years ago but I
believe in three to four or five years
it's gonna be really not good because
the 80 billion if 40 billion or 20
billion comes into Tick Tock and
Facebook and Instagram and whatever it
is be real Vine it's always going to
evolve
not if when that money comes in
everything I'm passionately
communicating to you right now will not
be as easy
there's a substantial opportunity in
2023 to take this underpriced attention
opportunity and really grow it and I
hope that we can go into q a we can go
and by the way when we get to q a don't
be don't be scared nobody's doing it
right so you all have the same questions
there's so much opportunity so please
ask questions in detail on this subject
matter but it is a substantial
substantial opportunity and very simply
put if you have one to three stores in
this unit any of the brands I believe
that you should be putting out somewhere
between five and fifteen posts on social
media a day
across three to four different platforms
and to the reaction I appreciate that
the reason I always get Jesus as a
response to that
is because most of you know you're
posting once a day if you're a super
[ __ ] star
once a week if you're like in it and
once a month if you're normal and never
if you're kind of 50 of this crowd so to
go from those numbers to hey everybody I
love you and like to see you win so much
that you email me and tell me I change
the course of your life but I need you
to post 15 times a day that sounds
outlandish
but to remind all of you almost every
brand in here is communicating things
around health and fitness to human
beings that they think is outlandish
for most human beings on Earth of the 8
billion doing the kind of exercise that
is required whether physically or
mentally and having the eating regimen
that is required to actually be in shape
is [ __ ] Jesus
they don't want to do it so a lot of
people in here are just Hypocrites
because you really sell it and live it
in physical but you don't live it in
marketing and business
and let's talk about the other part of
the m m management
look
I I give you a sense of how I grew up
I'm the least interested person in
entitlement I believe entitlement leads
to anxiety and depression I think
entitlement is poison however there are
way too many business owners in this
room that deploy very quick entitlement
on their employees based on age
discrimination without factoring in the
opportunities that 24 year olds have to
make money today just because you worked
for nine dollars an hour at Safeway
doesn't mean they should when they know
how to make thirty thousand dollars a
year making tick tocks
I understand what you would like the
kids to do for your business
but that is not the reality of the world
until business owners wake up to the
options
that the internet has created and start
really thinking about how they manage
not to be soft and fluffy I hate a
genzir as much as everybody else
but I know I also hate Boomers because I
know 40 000 Boomers that are lazy as
[ __ ]
this is not a generational thing
this is a human by human thing the
difference is when I was growing up in
the game if I had the options
to make money that the internet now
provides for me when I was 11 years old
[ __ ] graduating college I wouldn't have
graduated Middle School
we can't fight reality
there's way too many people in this
space because I watch it a little bit I
can't speak to anybody here individually
other than I saw some of the people
hashtag this event that I looked at
their accounts and paid attention how
much they're posting and you really
aren't posting
um
we can't fight reality
we can't fight the reality of where our
customers attention is I understand that
you've done direct mail and you're
comfortable with it and you don't know
how to run Facebook ads it doesn't
change the fact that Facebook ads
perfectly destroy Direct Mail perfectly
every day of the week
I understand you're comfortable with it
but it doesn't mean it's the truth
I understand you worked hard and grinded
and you expect everybody to do that but
your whole I walk 10 miles and 13 inches
of snow [ __ ] doesn't mean anything
we have to reverse engineer the reality
of the market that doesn't mean be soft
we have businesses to run
as a matter of fact I'll go the other
way
the amount of people that have Labor in
their stores every day
and there's nothing going on
should be required I mean if I could
control every business here I would have
every person in our stores that has
downtime producing tick tocks and
Instagram and YouTube instead of
standing there waiting for somebody to
come in
thank you
that's it for instance right this
doesn't have to be hard this has to be a
reframe of thinking when you hear 15 a
day it gets real scary when you know
that you have unlimited employees just
hanging around waiting for people to
[ __ ] come into the store
all of a sudden you get real excited
about we can do 40 a day if I get Carl
and Sally to do some [ __ ]
and all of a sudden you're not pissed
that they're on the phone dming trying
to hook up tonight you're pumped that
they're on the phone making some content
to drive your [ __ ] business
anybody named Carl or Sally in here
sorry sorry Carl
2023
is not 2015.
it's not 2009. it's definitely not 2
000.
and looking around it's definitely not
1994.
we have to adapt
mentally
the problem is the mainstream media and
social media are doing a phenomenal job
of talking about negativity and what's
wrong just certainly notes fear cells
most of the parents in this room use
fear to control what they want their
kids to do it's how it's How Humans are
wired
the DNA game and I have the greatest mom
in the world and a lot of great
circumstances that made me the reverse I
look at everything I just talked about
like if I'm sitting in this crowd
listening to this I'm pumped I want to
run through a wall and like take
everyone's money
look if you tweak your perspective on
how the world's operating
and instead of buying into the
propaganda for control of your mind you
look at the optimism that these tools
can create for you
if all of a sudden you look at your
employees like your teammates
literally I'm so affected by this if you
look at your employees I have 2 000
employees at vaynermedia alone
I genuinely think I work for them I
swear on my children's health I work for
them
of course you do if you're a great
leader and you want to build something
meaningful you work for them
I was raised by a dad who taught me the
reverse that that's why I know the
difference
and I used to be mad at my dad but then
I got kind of like a little bit older
and realized my dad grew up in the
Soviet Union where the country
controlled everything and the employees
stole everything the whole country ran
on the black market literally this is
the first like oh I'm so pumped I
mentioned earlier so it's my birthday
and I'm going to the liquor store and
I'm super sad no it's not my birthday
today I'm going back to the story
but it was my birthday a couple of weeks
ago so if you want to clap it up I'll
take it foreign
so it's my [ __ ] 14th birthday I'm
driving to the liquor store
as you may be able to tell by the way
I'm talking I talk all the time
my dad does not talk we're completely
the opposite
we live 45 minutes from the liquor store
because my dad wanted to have land
because he likes cows and pigs and [ __ ]
so we're 45 minutes from the liquor
store driving on Route 78 in New Jersey
to the liquor store
my dad says no words
I'm talking a mile a minute like I'm
coming in dad and like wait till you see
what I got I'm gonna sell every bottle
of wine like I'm like hyped even you
know like I was I didn't realize I was
gonna get paid two bucks an hour at this
point laughs
we pull up to the store after 45 minutes
he says not one word he turns to me and
he goes keep an eye on the employees
they like to steal
that's what my dad taught me I grew up
in that environment I grew up in an
environment where I watched an owner be
in conflict with his employees
and then I've run businesses for 25
years where I've done the reverse I'm
investor in over 500 companies and
watched closely on tons of boards I'm
watching this is my passion
yeah
if you cannot deploy empathy and
compassion for your employees I once
said something my dad brought up this
weekend actually I said Dad if everybody
who worked for you was you they wouldn't
work for you
I tell a lot of my friends who struggle
with their employees I'm like I had a
buddy who's like I just want them to
work as hard as me I'm like then give
them equity in the business
equal to you
we have to reframe this conversation you
have to make it enjoyable and
interesting not because you're soft
because you want to make money
this isn't like I'm not asking you to be
nice and reverse engineer them and be
compassionate because I'm Mother Teresa
I'm telling you because I want you to
build what you want professionally
you're out of options yes tons of people
are about to get fired tons you you do
not have a great resignation on your
hand next year you have more overclive
but overqualified people apply for your
business next year than you have in the
last 10 years that's good but if you
don't change the culture in every one of
your stores it's not going to mean
anything it's going to be a short-term
blip and it's not going to mean anything
you'll have no retention the second
those highly qualified people can get a
different job to pay more they're out
and more importantly while you've got
those qualified people they could if you
have a good culture they're going to
affect the kids who might be your future
managers
and so I highly recommend you get off of
your high horse on this issue we are
combative with our employee and again
I'm talking in generalization but this
is very common
and I just think we have to rethink it
you're not being soft you're not over
pandering you're not conforming to gen Z
ways you're not eating a [ __ ] blue
pill or red pill you're not doing that
[ __ ] you're just trying to run a
business and I'm telling you right now
the amount of 18 to 22 year olds who are
wildly aware that they can make the same
amount of money just making tick tocks
and making ads or going to thrift stores
and flipping [ __ ] or doing Amazon Prime
Drop Shipping or a million other they
just they're not lazy they have options
and we have to accept that and I highly
recommend you take a step back on this
issue because between marketing and
management if you really dial this and
look at it slightly different it can
have a tremendous impact on your
business tremendous impact those are the
two pillars in this scenario
franchise or franchisees what control
you have you two percent for the
marketing you have you can you don't you
know I'm sure they have some sort of
ideology of how much money you need to
spend in marketing what's cool for me is
I know if you just put that towards
making the content versus running the
ads you will do dramatically better then
when I know you're paying employees
anyway to stand around and you can get
them to do it so you have no additional
cost then I get really excited God
forbid you're sitting here with a little
Charisma or interest to be on camera now
we're [ __ ] flying
and by the way I want everybody here is
I'm not telling you
that you should be on camera some of you
are so awkward you should definitely not
be on camera
but if you're not awkward and you do
like it or if you're and here's a big
one if you're in the middle
just do it for a couple of months so you
can be the judge of the people that are
doing for you the number one mistake
people make is they're not practitioners
in it so they have no idea if they're 24
year old niece is doing a good job
if you just spend 10 hours and 10 weeks
living this it will have a substantial
impact on your business because the
Staggering returns that I see from
franchisees who take control of doing
output for them locally because
corporate needs to do corporate things
you know listen I'm on I'm on a board of
a qsr which has franchisees franchise
orders my marketing company does a ton
of this work like the franchisee
franchisor thing is got this
instead of crying about what they're
doing wrong or being pumped about what
they're doing right
you should be taking control of
everything you can be doing
right if that's what you want your
employees to do why don't you eat your
own medicine
you don't like what they're doing for
social you do it I really believe that I
really do not because I like them I
don't give a [ __ ] about them
I mean it it's because I like when
people take control of their Destiny
when they can
and this internet thing by the way if
this was 1987 you didn't have the money
to run commercials locally
if this was 1987 you weren't buying full
page ads in the newspaper that would it
was just too expensive this is practical
so if anything
and then I'm ready for Q a so I don't
know what a writers and you can Runners
where you at like thank you so there's
one on each side great one in the
corners one in the middle so in about a
minute or so please raise your hand and
we'll get to as many as possible with
any detailed question of anything I
talked about but I'll leave with this
wrap up the two biggest elephants in the
room that allow you to really grow next
year is how you actually treat your
employees and you put them in a position
to win and how you actually treat your
marketing and I have a feeling a lot of
you understood very quickly how it
doesn't have to be much more expensive
to get it done you just have to put in
the Reps you just have to put in the
Reps thank you
all right now by far thank you now by
far the best part I don't know about the
six of you that are leaving you're gonna
miss all the good [ __ ] I don't care that
you have to piss
stick it out all right hands up let's do
questions
we'll go in the middle first pick
anybody
stand up please and give me your name
please
such a pleasure thank you so
um
where social media leads for other
computer Studios
give me give me older we talking 70 to
90
no
[Music]
50 to 70. so where is it
just got it so couple things
Facebook
is like unbelievably good right now
because all the big companies canceled
Mark Zuckerberg and all the little
companies are a little scared with the
way it's going right now in December so
all the money's out of the system so the
organic reach is through the roof just
so everybody knows the way social works
is there's a feed
it's just inventory there's people's
attention all of us and then they fill
in if they don't have ads organic fills
it just people posting which is what I'm
trying to get you to do it if they have
ads those people will take precedent
that's how they make money but if the
demand is huge everything works so on
Tick Tock right now there's so much
consumption both ads and organic are
working on Facebook it went so crazy ads
for so long which is why their stock
price was so high for so long that it
was hard for us to get organic reach
Facebook fan page which a lot of you
might remember and again you can write
this down Google how do I build a
Facebook fan page if you haven't and
more importantly Facebook reels which
are similar to tick tocks and Instagram
reels have exploded Facebook dominates
50 to 70. as far as tick tock tick
tock's biggest growth right now is 50 to
70 because so many grandkids are getting
their grandparents on it you know this a
lot of you here know your parents are on
Tick Tock and they're in that demo or
you yourself are in that demo so
yes they will because it's coming but
Facebook reels are huge but then there's
also best practices for example every
one of these social media accounts as
I'm sure you know even if you're not
deep in it has a place where you can put
a link
of your home page or have you like it's
all strategy like that link is the most
important like where are you sending
that most people are on mobile a lot of
people I see in this SMB franchisee
World they'll put a link that isn't even
mobile optimized so they saw the tick
tock or the Instagram post but then they
clicked the link because they're
interested but then like the whole
experience is crap and they're out so is
your website mobile optimized should you
send it to a website you create that
just has a phone number and an email
like you have to be it's you have to be
smart that's part of it but I think
Facebook reels is a real place for you
to focus on
and again that 15 comes 15 posts leg
comes in the mindset of three times five
three posts a day
Instagram
YouTube shorts has exploded if you know
what that is YouTube shorts again you
can write that down and Google it tick
tock LinkedIn has become a monster
LinkedIn for this industry because I
made a post six months ago about it and
have been reached out by several people
in Fitness with locations LinkedIn is
acting like Facebook did seven years ago
so you get a LinkedIn account you just
post Fitness and then you make it
tailored to the business world right
think you have no time because you're a
busy executive 15 like you start playing
with the context so that's that you got
it I think LinkedIn would also be strong
for 50 to 70 is really strong on
LinkedIn but again context matters so if
you know you're posting on LinkedIn you
may make a reference of burnout at work
whereas if you're posting on Tick Tock
you might make you want to keep up with
your kids and your grandkids it's the
psychology that matters
[Music]